all right we missed hatred mail last
week because of the David Pakman show
staff summer vacation but it is back
quick reminder what is hatred mail
teachers can buy their own school
supplies but will throw in the Glock for
free Patriot mail written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America
and because freedom this this week's
hatred mail introduces a notable term
let me put it that way let's take a
listen to it
eggy fing [ __ ] click baked Pakman once
again don't you ever learn I'm generally
unsubscribing how about you hop off
buddy anybody can see what you're doing
nothing personal but you are a Jew a
pretty obvious Jew at that yes you're
white David because Ashkenazi Jews are
actually Italians you're a Spanish
speaking Italian who thinks he's a Jew
must be tough kid I'm an obvious Jew
that's interesting so I guess the
implication is that there would be
subtle Jews and then there are obvious
Jews I'm in the latter category
apparently the best way to fight hate
reott ISM in your local community is to
become a member at join pakman.com
utilizing the coupon code hatred for th8
e r io t for 0 when you use the coupon
code hay tree at 40 you save 40% off of
your membership and hey tree 'it's cry
because they are extremely saddened by
the fact that they're hate reott ism is
only furthering financial support of the
david pakman show that's how I see it
anyway I know that might not literally
be how people see it but go to join
pakman.com pick your membership of
choice apply the coupon code hey tree at
40 and get 100% of the member perks but
with a 40% discount